there are a ton of fixed income assets
and other types of credit assets that
appear to not be doing so well but now
that we have higher levels of inflation
over five percent cpi many of those
assets are actually producing uh very
low returns or even negative yielding on
a real return basis how big is this
problem when we think of the credit
markets first of all uh total global
credit
is 400 trillion dollars
okay that dwarfs the equity market which
is approximately 100 trillion us dollars
so you can see why you need to
understand and
you need to understand what's happening
in the dog because it's just a much
bigger market it's traded by
very sophisticated institutions but
within that market you know we have
government debt we have municipalities
states we have corporations we have junk
bonds we have structured product it's a
it's a big animal um and in various
parts of that animal there's some weird
things happening so let's start with one
of the most weird things
uh there is over 15 trillion dollars of
negative yielding
bonds in the world now they're mostly
sovereign bonds but there are a few
corporate bonds in europe that uh they
have negative yield which means the
buyer of that bond is actually going to
lose money by investing in that bond if
they hold that bond to maturity a lot of
them will say well i'm smarter than the
market and i'm going to buy it now in
anticipation of yields going even more
negative and therefore there's a price
gain in those bonds but that's like
picking up nickels in front of a
steamroller right it's a dumb dumb
investment policy
but many of these investment mandates
have to own bonds so you mentioned the
60 40 traditional 60 equities 40 bonds
those mandates were written pomp when
interest rates were at levels that you
could make a decent return so when i
started trading bonds in the 1990s well
late 80s actually us treasury tenure was
double digits
now it's 1.6 something percent i mean
you got to understand it that's been a
40 year bull market in bonds and that is
done because it's only mathematics you
can't make
excess returns over the contractual
returns that are in bonds so first of
all you have these negative yielding
bonds which are not assets anymore
they're actually liabilities so
congratulations you're investing in an
asset it's actually going to cost you
money contractually it will cost you
money
well that's 15 trillion of loser money
right there then you look at some of the
bigger things that are going on so my
expertise was in uh formulated in the
high yield bond market high yield bonds
right now
yield around four percent that's the
merrill lynch
uh
high yield index yields four percent and
i need to point this out that four
percent is before
expected and unexpected default losses
so you'll say foss what are you talking
about i'll say very simply look
high-yield bonds have an expected
component of default because over time
high-yield bonds do default not the
whole industry but a portion of it so
there's an expected loss in that four
percent
and then there's also what i call
unexpected losses when you hit a
recession when you hit some sort of
contagion when there's a systemic risk
to the market you get unexpected losses
so it could be idiosyncratic all i'm
throwing at a lot of these technical
jargon at the end of the day you are
earning four percent before
losses so let's calculate some expected
and unexpected losses in there and then
account for inflation which you
correctly pointed out if you believe the
cpi is accurate
you're earning
negative return real returns after
inflation and piddly
nominal returns before expected and
unexpected default losses i've never
seen a worse risk return
potential for fixed income in my 32
years and i'm gonna add one thing and
this is the kicker
if cpi
was actually measured
the same way as the original formula in
1980
cpi would be 14
not 5.
wow
14 pom